ان الله تعالى امرنا بامر بدا فيه بنفسه
وثنى بملائكه قدسه وثلث بالمؤمنين من عالم
جنه وانسه وقال تعالى قولا كريما تعظيما
لقدر نبينا وتفهما لنا وتعليما ان الله
وملائكته يصلون على النبي يا ايها الذين
امنوا صلوا عليه وسلموا
تسليما اللهم صل وسلم وبارك
واكرم وانعم وتحنن وتعطف على سيدنا محمد
طب القلوب ودوائها وعافيه الابدان وشفائها
ونور الابصار وضيائها وعلى اله وصحبه وسلم
تسليما كثيرا
كثيرا
سستر
يم بفور ذا
عيد ماي خطبه
سيدنا اسماعيل عليه
السلام
مكه سيدنا اسماعيل سيدنا ابراهيم عليه
ا
اسمايل
الله has commanded me to build a house
here in
this will you help
me will you help
me that
father leave his son and his
‏long
time
when
ask سيدنا اسماعيل عليه
السلام
اسماعيل عليه
السلام ابراهيم عليه
[Silence]
السلام ربنا
تقبلنا انك انت السميع
[Silence]
العليم الله سبحانه
وتالى سيدنا
اسماعيل عليه
السلام سيدنا ابراهيم عليه
السلام
احديث ابن عس رضي الله
عنهما the prophets are
revelation
in
s
الله سبحانه
و
friend
pleas الله
خيرا
[Silence]
سيدنا ابراهيم عليه
السلام
السلام سيدنا
ابراهيم اسيل عليه
السلام
اسمايل عليه
السلام my
father do what you have been
commed
me
ستجدني ان شاء الله من
[Silence]
الصبرين الله سبحانه
وتالى ‏and when they
submitted place place it on this
fore submitted here means that he obeed
his lord's command and showed his in to
follow
it الله سبحانه وتالى
sayah
you
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتعالى ‏we put a saf in the
place بذبح
عظيم
that in
parad
جبريل عليه
السلام الله اكبر الله
اكبر سيدنا
ابراهيم لا اله الا
الله سيدنا جبريل عليه السلام
الله اكبر الله
اكبر ان سيدنا اسماعيل
ر ولله
الحمد الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد اللهم الاسلام والمسلمين امين واعلي
كلمتي الحق والدين اللهم وفقنا لما تحب
وترضى اللهم اجعل جمعنا هذا جمعا مرحوما
وتفرقنا من بعده تفرقا معصوما ولا تجعل
فينا ولا معنا شقيا او محروما اللهم ات
انفسنا تقواها وزكها انت خير من زكاها انت
وليها ومولاها اللهم اغفر لحي
وميتنا صغيرنا وكبيرنا ذكرانا وانثانا
اللهم اغفر لنا
ولوالدينا وللجماع الحاضرين ووالديهم
الذين شهدوا لك بالوحدانيه ولنبيك
بالرساله وماتوا على ذلك ان الله يامر
بالعدل والاحسان وايتاء ذي القربى وينهى
عن الفحشاء والمنكر والبغي يعظكم لعلكم
تذكرون واقم الصلاه يرحمك الله